>> Tucker: THE WORLD ECONOMIC
FORUM IN DAVOS, SWITZERLAND IS
GOING ON AS WE SPEAK.
YOU WEREN'T INVITED.
1,000 PRIVATE JETS HAVE SHOWED
UP SPEWING VAST AMOUNTS OF
CARBON.
A BIG TOPIC IN DAVOS WHY IT
ALWAYS IS WHEN RICH PEOPLE
GATHER AND MANY ARE CLAIMING WE
NEED DRASTIC ACTIONS.
I LIKE HOW IT WORKS.
I FLY IN MY PRIVATE PAIN AND YOU
HAVE TO STOP EATING HAMBURGERS
AND WALK AND IT BALANCES OUT.
>> THIS IS A THE WAY THESE GUYS
PLAN.
SOMEHOW THEY WILL STILL GET TO
LAUNDRY ON THE ROCKS WITH THE
VILLAGE WOMEN GETTING YOUR
CLOTHES DRY BECAUSE THE WASHER
AND DRYER ARE DESTROYING THE
PLANET.
THE FACT THEY ALL MEET IN A
REMOTE LUXURY SWISS SKI RESORT.
YOU SAID MOST AREN'T INVITED
BECAUSE IT'S STAKEHOLDERS AND
90% OF THE SLUMPS DON'T HAVE A
STAKE IN IT BUT CATE BLANCHETT
IS A STAKEHOLDER RECEIVING AN
AWARD.
THEY SHOULD HAVE GIVEN AN AWARD
FOR THE AWARENESS OF REFUGEES
BECAUSE THERE WERE SO MANY IT
I WE DON'T NEED CATE BLANCHETT
TO RAISE AWARENESS.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE AT DAVOS THE
LEADERS OF THE WORLD'S LARGEST
DEMOCRACIES AND POLITICAL
LEADERS AND HOW MANY DO YOU
THINK REALLY BELIEVE IN
DEMOCRACY FOR REAL?
>> I DON'T THINK THEY DO AND
THAT'S WHAT'S FASCINATING THEY
REGARD THINGS LIKE THE TRUMP
ELECTION AND BREXIT AND THE RICE
OF THE NEW LEADER IN FRANCE AS
ABERRATIONS AND PROOF DEMOCRACY
HAS TO BE MODERATED BY ALL THE
SENSIBLE CLEVER PEOPLE GETTING
TOGETHER IN A SWISS SKI RESORT
TOP OF THE MOUNTAIN IN THE BOND
FILM ON HER MAJESTY'S SECRET
SERVICE IF YOU'RE KEEPING IN
TOUCH WITH YOUR WORLD CON SPIR
TOUCH WITH YOUR WORLD CON SPI
SPIR -- CONSPIRATORS AND DECIDE
THE MEASURES TO AMELIORATE THE
VOICE OF THE PEOPLE BECAUSE IT'S
VULGAR AND KEEPS VOTING FOR
TRUMP AND BREXIT.
>> Tucker: DON'T YOU THINK THE
PEOPLE INVOLVED SHOULD BE
IMPRESSIVE AND SELF AWARE AND
SMART?
>> I THINK SO.
IT'S BECOME A THIRD-RATE
PRIVATE JETS.
IT'S A CLASS THING SO THERE'S
SAUDI PRINCES AND TRASHY
CELEBRITIES AND POWERFUL
BUSINESS LEADERS.
AT HEART IT IS AN
ANTI-DEMOCRATIC BIAS.
YOU SAID HAMBURGERS CAUSE GLOBAL
ITS ICE FLOTE  SO THE ENTIRE
PLANET COULD BE KAPUT BECAUSE
THAT CAUSES GLOBAL WARMING.
>> Tucker: NEXT JANUARY, YOU AND
I ARE GOING.
LET'S DO A SHOW.
THAT WOULD BE SO COOL.
>> AND WE'LL GO ON YOUR PERSONAL